All right. This is the, uh,
second of two lectures, uh,
from Lawrence Summers.
Uh, me just say again,
this is the a o chem
lecture series off of,
created by an anonymous donor in honor
of Arthur oaken at the last lecture.
I was very pleased to hear the number
of fond memories very summers has of
Arthur oaken. Uh, so, uh,
at today's lecture, uh,
I think some people felt that we didn't
have enough time for question and answer.
Uh,
and so we plan to allocate
a half hour to that.
Does that sound good? So, uh, Larry will
well,
um,
wrap up just before the hour and
we'll have a good discussion.
[inaudible]
okay.
Judging by the discussions,
I had an opportunity to
have lunch and a dinner.
I would suggest a, a, a,
a proposal for a, for you, Bob, with
respect to next year's Okin lecture.
Um, invite the Oakland lecturer
to give his first lecture,
then let him have dinner and let them
have lunch with the Yale Faculty and then
let him ponder what he's been told for
three weeks and invite him to come back
and encourage him to emphasize
what he was told rather than,
um,
any ideas he might have and you would get
substantially better oak and lectures.
I suspect as a con, as
a consequence if, uh,
the feedback that I got,
um, is, uh, any guide,
I want to thank everybody, uh,
for their hospitality. And I,
uh, having seen a certain number of, uh,
these kinds of lecture series over
time when I was president of Harvard,
uh, my deepest nightmare,
one of my deepest nightmares,
some of might do my nightmares actually
came true, but some of my lesser deeper,
lesser nightmares as president of
Harvard for the sequential lecture series
where at the third lecture,
no one came.
And so as a lecturer, I, uh,
was concerned the judgment of those
who have seen the product is a of more
interest in the judgment
of those who have not.
So the fact that the room looks a little
bit like the room looked yesterday,
I take as at least mild
encouragement and a validation,
uh, to, uh, proceed.
Yesterday I talked about two types of,
uh,
recessions,
what referred to as disinflation
recessions in which the Fed stepped on the
brakes,
the economy slowed,
the feds stepped off the brakes,
the economy reaccelerating.
And what was my larger, uh, focus, uh,
financial system breakdown recessions
in which in one way or another,
bubbles burst or banks faced liquidity
problems where the supply of finance,
uh,
dried up and the economy suffered.
I suggested that the latter category of
recession was the historical pattern of
procession,
that there were some signs that
the more relevant problem for,
uh,
the United States going forward
might well be the latter kind of,
uh, uh, might well be, uh, the ladder, uh,
kind of recession, uh, as well.
And I implied,
I thought I will develop a,
in the course of these remarks
that, uh, the incipient recession,
uh,
in the United States is almost certainly
of the ladder financial breakdown,
a variety rather than,
uh,
the disinflation a variety.
We have had a instructive,
uh,
for me,
conversations at a both dinner and
lunch on the question of how one thinks
about,
uh,
these two categories of recession
in the context of an ISL m,
uh, model or in the context of a, uh,
simple, uh, some kind of a simple,
a macro economic model.
The correct answer to that question I
think is that it's pretty unambiguous that
a disinflation recession is best thought
of as the Federal Reserve tightening
money,
which represents some kind of leftward
movement of the LM curve that output,
uh,
declined and interest rates rise.
And that that's the proximate a shock
that is bringing about the recession,
that it turns out to be a
matter of semantic ambiguity.
What,
how to think about a financial crisis,
a recession in the context
of a simple macro model.
Everybody agrees on the movement of
three variables in such a recession,
output goes down, queue goes, uh,
down and short term
interest rates go down.
One instinct,
which is probably not the first
instinct in the city of new haven,
is to think of that recession in a
traditional ISL m curve with the I s curve
and the LM curve beings plotted in a space
determined by the level of output and
the short term interest
rate in that formulation.
It is clearly an I asked shock
the level of output declines,
the level of interest
rates decline, uh, as well.
And alternative of formulation and a
formulation that is probably more in the
spirit of a Yale economics is to think
of the ISL m diagram as having been drawn
in a space that focuses on output and
the required return to capital or focuses
on output and queue.
And in a formulation of that kind,
there hasn't been a shock
to the relationship between
investment in the price of
capital. There's been a shock to, uh,
the price of capital at any given
level of the short term interest rate.
And so one thinks of it as part
of the dynamics of the LM curve.
However,
one views that a question of the
IRS curve versus the LM curve,
the operative, uh,
distinction between, uh,
the two kinds of shocks is
that in a disinflation shock,
interest rates are up and that is why
output is down in a financial breakdown.
Shock output is down and that is
why policy interest rates were safe.
Uh, interest rates are
reduced from that perspective.
It's very clear what the current uh,
episode is.
As expectations of future output have
declined as asset prices have declined,
one is seen very substantial declines
in a treasury bond yields and in uh,
the federal funds rate for those
who are aficionados of such things.
I will mention that
for a period of a week,
the five year tips yield
was significantly nit,
was negative at one point
reaching negative 22 basis points.
And that there was a brief three hour
period in Japan when the one month
treasury bill was yielding.
Not two basis points,
not one basis point,
but literally a zero basis points as a
consequence of various machinations in
the money market that had
the character of an extreme,
a flight to safety.
If one thinks about the duration and
the policy response to recessions of uh,
these two kinds,
they are usefully distinguished the
policy response and the dynamics of
disinflation.
Recessions are not profoundly complicated.
The Fed steps on the brakes depending
on how hard the Fed steps on the brakes,
the recessions duration is uncertain
at a firt at a certain point when it is
satisfied that sufficient disinflation
has taken place or when it feels that
other imperatives take precedence,
the Fed removes its foot from the brakes,
allow short term interest rates to decline
and eventually the economy expands.
There's no great mystery about it.
The length and depth of the recession is
closely tied to the strength force and
length of the Fed tightening
and the speed with which, uh,
it eases.
Hence,
there was much more disinflation to
be done in 1980 82 and the recession
interest rates were pushed up much
further. The recession was, uh,
that much more severe.
The matter is much more complex.
When one turns to,
uh,
financial, uh, turns, uh,
to financial overextension,
uh, recessions.
Thinking about the limited sample of data,
it falls into two broad categories.
Uh,
the first is the recessions that
didn't happen or happened only barely.
There was a pretty exciting financial
crisis in 1987 and nothing really
happened.
Uh,
there was a pretty exciting financial
crisis for those involved in 1998 and in
neither case, if I gave you the data
on unemployment, GNP consumption,
any real variable,
and I didn't give you the timescale,
and I said, what year did we have
a percent stock market crash?
What year did we have a really dramatic
set of dislocations in financial
markets? As a major hedge fund failed,
you wouldn't be able to see it.
Even the 2001,
a recession,
which was associated with
the bursting of the Nasdaq.
A bubble is a pretty minimalist recession,
uh,
in retrospect, uh, with,
uh, the data revised,
there is no two quarter
period when, uh, Ga,
when GDP declined,
there are too pure to quarters.
Uh,
in which GDP declined put,
they're separated by a quarter
of modest positive growth.
So it is not the case that all financial
crises or even most financial crises
lead,
uh,
to economic downturns and some
have a natural explanation of that.
Essentially they explained that the
financial sector is only one small part of
uh,
the economy that the decline
in the financial sector
of the economy is a not of
that much a consequence.
And with reasonable policy responses
either with monetary policy or with fiscal
policy and automatic stabilizers,
any loss and demand, uh, can, uh,
be offset.
A not a typical calculation
of this kind would say,
suppose the stock market
lost 20% of its value.
If the value of the stock market is
on the order of the value of a GNP,
that's a loss of 20% of a GNP.
If the marginal propensity to
consume out of wealth is a 4%,
the loss is a 10th of a percent of Gen p
and amount that an economy would rather
not lose,
but hardly the difference between
economic success and economic failure and
something that's potentially
offset. Uh, if there is, uh,
some, uh, policy of response.
And so there is data and evidence,
uh,
for the view that,
a significant amount of financial
disruption can take place with relatively
little consequence for,
uh, the real economy.
The difficulty is that there are other
data points as well as 1987 and 19,
uh, 98 and, uh,
2001,
there are data points to come from the
United States in the aftermath of 1929.
While those perhaps or in so different
and institutional environment with such
agregious errors as to,
uh, not be relevant.
There are data points from, uh, Japan, uh,
during the 1990s.
There are any number of data points
of from emerging markets in which,
uh, the reality of financial problems, uh,
created a very large, uh, losses,
uh,
output.
And so it's natural to ask why is
the response to a financial crises,
uh,
so heterogeneous with some episodes
in which they seem to have very little
consequence and some episodes
in which they seem to have.
Uh, so, uh,
very much I think the natural,
uh,
explanation though it's a difficult to
prove in any kind of a conclusive a way
is an idea that runs through the work
of many economists. And probably in,
uh, recent, uh, decades,
uh, most strongly, uh,
through Ben Bernanke, he's, uh,
work suggesting that financial
intermediation capital is a substantial
contributor to the production process.
And when it is destroyed,
uh,
suddenly there are substantial losses
both to aggregate supply and to aggregate
a demand.
I made this point,
tried to make this point graphic in a
conversation with one of your colleagues
by asking, uh, the question.
Suppose one considered the following
macro economic shock for the next six
months.
It will not be possible to make and
complete a phone call in the United in the
United States.
What would be likely to happen to the GDP
of the United States and what would be
likely to happen to the performance of,
uh,
the American economy?
It's actually sort of an interesting
question and I don't have a clue exactly
what the right answer is.
My strong suspicion is that it
would really be quite a bad event,
uh, for the performance of the
economy. The question of whether, um,
the telephone lines would transmit a bits,
uh,
would obviously be very important in
a where would only stop working for,
for the human voice would be
a very important determinant.
But in either case,
it's hard to believe that there would
not be substantial loss of output and
significant loss of employment as well.
There would be many methods for
seeking to estimate the value of,
uh,
the losses.
But I would argue that a particularly
poor method would be to ask what's the
market value of all the
telephone companies?
Let's say the market value of all the
telephone companies is $1 trillion.
If they're not going to earn
anything for a year than a,
their market value will
go down by $400 billion.
So we'll multiply $400 billion
by a marginal propensity to,
uh,
demand marginal propensity to consume,
and we'll add something for the
fact and we'll call that lost.
I've lost demand and we'll say there
needs to be some increased demand because
we need to fix the phone,
we need to fix the telephones.
And so that'll be some
increased investment that would,
it seems to me be the wrong mode
of analysis that in some way,
one would want to capture
the idea that the protect,
that the production potential of the
economy would be lower because the
opportunities to generate output out of
a given amount of capital and a given
amount of labor would be impossible
without the intercommunication that the
telephone,
uh,
makes possible the results I would suggest
of that telephone shock would be lost
output and would also be lost output
without substantial disinflation a benefit
because the last output would not come,
uh,
in a way that created gluts of goods,
hanging over markets that
lead to declines in prices.
The benefit in terms of disinflation of
a downturn induced by the inability to
make a phone call would be much less
then the benefit of a similar loss of
output achieved,
uh,
through the more standard tools
of fiscal and monetary policy.
I emphasize this last point because it
connects with the observation with which
I began yesterday that declines in,
uh, output associated with
financial crisis recession.
If avoidable probably create a welfare
gain of the kind that aren't Okin focused
so much on my end of the kind that Jim
Tobin emphasized when he spoke of all
those Harberger triangles filling and
Okin a gap and are not susceptible to the
critique that,
uh,
what you lose on the swings you gain on
the swerves that's associated with the
more conventional view of
cyclical, uh, fluctuations.
It should be clear from what I have said,
um, where I am, uh, going,
my suggestion is really to echo,
uh,
Ben Bernanke,
he's a suggestion that the destruction
of financial intermediation,
uh,
capital should be thought of as
reducing the economy's potential,
uh, to, uh,
generate output in that process,
making people poorer and
reducing the level of demand as,
uh,
well when that process kicks in to a
substantial extent that I would suggest is
the occasion on which financial crises
proved to be exciting events outside of
the precincts of, uh, Manhattan and, uh,
Chicago.
And the crucial question
for economic policy.
I in responding, uh, to, uh, these, uh,
crises I would suggest is preventing
on that kind of destruction of
intermediation capital from
taking place on a large scale.
And that brings me to the policy task,
uh, that, uh,
the US authorities a face at,
uh,
the current, uh, moment.
I like to define,
uh,
the problem as managing
and containing three Ah,
three separate a vicious cycle mechanisms.
The first is the one that I spoke,
I spoke about at length, uh,
yesterday.
What one might call the
a psycho the tendency,
I'm more than a tendency in the
market for fixed income instruments,
particularly mortgage backed securities,
um,
to some degree in the market for housing
for declines in value to give rise to
selling pressures that create further
declines in value reinforcing,
uh, the, uh, vicious cycle.
The second a vicious
cycle which builds on,
uh,
that is what is traditionally
referred to as the credit accelerator.
A Psycho II deteriorating financial
economy leads to less lending leads to a
deteriorating really economy leads to
less capacity to pay back a debt leads to
declining values of a financial
instruments leads to further reductions in
lending and the cycle continues.
And the third cycle,
the third potentially destabilizing
mechanism is the one that's perhaps most
familiar.
The Keynesian mechanism in which reduced
spending leads to reduced income leads
to reduce spending and,
uh,
on containing these mutually reinforcing,
cycles is I would suggest now the
central challenge for economic policy.
I am not in a position to make a
authoritative estimates of some of the
relevant, uh, magnitudes.
And I don't want my estimates
to be given more seriousness.
Uh, then, uh, their crudity, uh,
deserves,
which is why I'm not
projecting them on a screen.
But let me give you
some round numbers that,
uh,
are quite close to the judgment of
the various investment banks and,
uh, informed observers who
have studied these questions.
The intermediate,
the Equity Capital of leveraged financial
institutions in the United States
totals about $2 trillion.
It totaled a little more than two
train dollars a few months ago.
It probably totals a little less than
a few trees. Then $2 trillion. Uh,
today that $2 trillion of,
uh, capital, uh,
supported about $20
trillion of asset holding.
In other words,
those institutions were levered 10 to one.
Some were levered much
more than 10 to one.
Fannie Mae or Freddie Mac
are, for example, levered 30,
uh,
to one.
A bank with an 8% capital
requirement is levered. Uh,
12, uh, two, uh,
one others,
hedge funds pursuing a certain
strategies are levered considerably less,
uh, then, uh, 10 to one. But on average,
the leverage works out to about 10 to one,
$2 trillion of equity capital,
$20 trillion of, uh, lending
the losses that have,
uh,
taken place over the last,
nine months and the projected losses based
on reasonable models of fundamentals.
These are not mark to market losses
that build in what might be market over
reactions.
These are estimates of what will
happen to mortgage securities based on
assumptions that for example,
house prices will decline by
another 15% from current levels.
Estimates of,
uh,
those total losses are
about a trillion dollars.
That trillion dollar figure sounds very
scary relative to $2 trillion of capital
in the intermediation sector.
But good news about half those losses
are outside the financial intermediary.
A sector there, a bill
Brainerd's pension. Um,
there, uh, the state of
Nebraska is a pension fund.
They're the Yale endowment, their
life insurance companies. Um,
and uh,
the like,
so about half are held by levered,
uh, are held by levered, uh,
intermediaries and more good news.
Um,
but levered intermediaries are mostly
sooner or later in one way or another,
going to get tax deductions
of various kinds.
And so when all is said and done,
the losses of capital to
the intermediation sector
represent about 300 billion,
uh,
dollars.
$300 billion of lost capital has been
offset so far by about $150 billion of
capital that has been raised in city
groups deal with Abu Dhabi and the like.
And so lost capitol,
which is,
which can be estimated with some degree
of accuracy compared to the next step
in, uh, this, uh,
calculation represents,
um,
about 150,
$1 billion,
$150 billion of lost capital at 10 to
one leverage means a trillion dollar,
trillion and a half dollars
of lost intermediation,
uh,
capacity or about seven and a half percent
of the financial asset holding that
was previously taking place.
Now here comes a wildcard.
What should happen to the leverage of
intermediaries in the face of the events
of the last nine months?
Well,
first of all,
they probably should have learned from
the last nine months that the degree of
leverage with which they were operating
nine months ago was excessive.
Second,
they almost certainly will judge that
the volatility associated with the assets
they hold and the degree of uncertainty
about their portfolios is today very
substantially greater.
Not just then they thought
it was nine months ago,
but then that objective
Lee was nine months ago.
And third,
the,
the magnitude of tail risk of existential
events which will cause the solvency
of their institution to
come into fundamental, uh,
doubt has surely increased as well.
I don't think we have a sound basis for
estimating how much prudent institutions
will reduce,
uh,
their leverage and the leverage choices
they make will of course be very much
influenced in some cases by the way
in which the government applies.
Uh, capital, uh,
rules if one makes the c conservative,
but in my view,
not absurd assumption that
leverage will be reduced by 10%.
10% leverage,
a 10% reduction in leverage on a $20
trillion base of asset holding represents
the loss of another $2
trillion in lending capacity.
Add the one and a half
trillion dollars and uh,
the to $1 trillion and you are looking
at the loss of on the order of three and
a half trillion dollars or on the
order of 15% of the previous financial
intermediation capacity.
It is not unreasonable at all to
suppose that this is a shock that is of
substantial magnitude relative to the
functioning of the financial system.
And to the extent that the economy
is dependent on the ability, uh,
to get credit to the functioning
of the economy and that route,
it is the challenge of policy to
address this shock in this environment.
What are the tools that
are available on to,
uh,
policy makers?
The first imperative of a policy
and one that has been pursued,
uh, in this crisis since
the beginning of 2008,
or be it in my judgment, uh, somewhat, uh,
belatedly is to seek to
maintain aggregate demand.
Whatever else is happening and
environment of this kind is likely to be a
disinflationary uh,
environment over time.
It is likely to be an environment
in which if spending is reduced,
asset values will decline further
compounding the degree of economic damage.
How do policy makers seek to maintain,
uh,
aggregate demand before these,
before the events of the last,
uh,
18 months?
If asked to comment on this subject,
I would have said,
uh,
the dominant tool of short
run stabilization policy
should be monetary policy,
fiscal policy.
And I would have explained that a fiscal
policy except in the shortest of runs
was likely to be offset by the Federal
Reserve and so it would end up affecting
the composition of output,
not the level of output,
and I would further have explained that
it was much more destructive of long run
values to try to very spending or the
tax structure in a short run way in order
to stabilize the economy and that that
was best accomplished through a monetary
policy.
I continue to regard that as a reasonable
judgment about policy in normal times,
but it seems to me that while it is
appropriate in this environment to seek to
use monetary policy as a tool of stimulus,
there are several considerations that
suggests that it should not be the sole
tool of stimulus in this environment.
First,
there is much more than the normal degree
of uncertainty about what the impact
of changes in interest rates will
be on the level of aggregate demand.
Imagine,
for example,
an intermediary that
is capital constraint.
It only has $1 billion of capital and
it therefore can only lend $10 billion.
Imagine now that the rate
of interest is brought down,
it can still only lend $10 billion and
the rate at which it lens will still be
the point at which the demand curve
for its loans is act $10 billion.
The only result of bringing down the
interest rate will be a reduction in its
cost of funding,
which over time will allow
it to rebuild a it's capitol.
But that is a very slow process,
a very different situation than the
more normal situation in which the
intermediary is not constraint.
Is this the case for most intermediaries?
It's very difficult to know.
Most intermediaries are not
at their capital constraint,
but they probably are planning for
some given cushion relative to uh,
their capital constraint.
In this environment,
it is likely that the multiplier from
monetary policy is less and did he surely
more uncertain. And that is an
inhibition to the use of monetary policy.
Second inhibition to the use of monetary
policy as a sole tool is most of the
time with respect to
most economic policies,
we may not know what the multiplier
associated with the instrument is,
but we know where,
uh,
we have set the policy dial through
all of modern economic experience,
uh,
until uh,
nine months ago it would be completely
impossible to use any known econometric
technique to say anything about the
impact of changes in the Fed funds rate as
distinct from changes in library on
the behavior of the aggregate economy
because they were perfectly here as the
spread between them was small and little
fluctuating in the last nine months,
a substantial spread has emerged
between the Fed funds rate,
the rate at which banks lend
to each other, uh, overnight.
And the,
uh,
interbank rate that prevails over a
longer horizons for a variety of reasons
that I don't have time
to get into. It is, uh,
almost certainly the case that large
parts of this spread reflect the credit
risk, uh, that banks
experience, uh, when, uh,
they lend to each other.
Probably the right indicator for monetary
policy is not the Fed funds rate,
but he's live war in which case there
has been rather less easing of monetary
policy then looking at the
Fed funds rate would suggest,
but one cannot make that
decision in a definitive way.
And so easing monetary policy as the Fed
has been doing for some time and as the
Fed did today in lowering the rate another
25 basis points is almost certainly
appropriate,
but it is almost certainly not appropriate
to rely only on a single instrument
in this context because one is uncertain
about how much of that instrument is,
one is applied because one is uncertain
about what the multiplier of that
instrument is. And because
in the current, uh,
context,
there are reasons to be concerned
about the pernicious side effects of
excessively low interest
rates to stand out.
Uh, the first, uh, while in general,
I am very much with,
uh,
the Keynesian consensus that the inflation
process depends upon a aggregate,
uh,
do aggregate demand in
the current context.
A lower interest rates may well contribute
directly to the inflation process
through their impact on the dollar and
through their impact on commodity prices.
The second while,
I give less weight than most to
critiques of a to critiques of the policy
environment that blame our
current problems on the fact
that interest rates were
kept a low for a long time
responding to the last,
uh,
recession.
It seems to me reasonable to give some
weight to the concern that excessively
low interest rates set the
stage for future bubbles.
I therefore think it's appropriate that,
uh,
the congress acted and I suspect the
congress wold need to act again to provide
fiscal stimulus, uh, to, uh,
the economy in advocating fiscals
in advocating a fiscal stimulus,
uh,
just after the turn of the year.
I urge that the stimulus be timely
because experience suggests that,
uh,
the difficulty of lags in implementation
have traditionally been serious with
respect to fiscal policy
that it be targeted,
uh,
designed to generate as
much spending as possible,
as quickly as possible,
which meant that tax breaks should be
channeled to those with lower incomes
rather than those with higher incomes.
That recommendation was adopted,
meant that,
uh,
taxes meant that a benefit programs
that went to people like food stamps and
unemployment insurance recipients who
were likely to have a very high marginal
propensity to consume the political
process was unwilling, uh,
to, uh, do was, was unwilling, uh,
to,
uh,
do that and the fiscal
stimulus be temporary in light
of the seriousness of the
country's long run a fiscal problems.
So macro economic policy in,
uh,
this,
environment can help to maintain,
uh,
aggregate demand,
but it does not address the disruption
in the productive mechanism associated
with the decline in the
financial sectors capacity.
Uh, for, uh, intermediation.
There are a number of tools
of policy directed at, uh,
the maintenance of, uh,
financial stability.
One has received overwhelming emphasis
today and it is entirely appropriate,
but I would suggest
presumptively insufficient.
And that is the Fed through a dizzying
array of new facilities and ad hoc
actions has made clear that it stands
ready against good collateral to provide
liquidity to financial institutions.
Now go back to the calculations.
Uh,
that I went through a moment ago.
I emphasized the loss of capital and
I represented the desired reduction in
levels of leverage associated
with a more risky environment.
I did not say anything in doing those
calculations about the difficulty of
attracting funds,
about the difficulty of borrowing funds,
I did not raise the concern
about a bank runs and,
uh,
the life,
the provision of liquidity
by the Fed is necessary.
Without it in my judgment,
it is very likely that we would have
seen problematic runs on a number of
institutions.
I believe the Fed behaved in a broadly
correct way in responding to the events
at a bear Sterns.
It is certainly possible that if the
Fed had not acted the losses to bear
Stearns shareholders
would have been total.
There would have been
substantial disruption in the
bond markets for a period of
five days,
a valuable lesson would have been taught
and the matter and the world would have
moved forward. It is certainly
possible that that is the case.
It seems to me one doesn't need to
assign a very high probability to the
alternative scenario in which
runs on bear Stearns cascaded,
uh, to other institutions, um,
which then cascaded to other institutions
and led to substantial destruction of
many institutions that were
thought previously viable.
I don't think one has to assign
a very great probability, uh,
to the latter of event to believe that
a rescue of bear Stearns was worthwhile.
And I myself would co would assign
a much greater than 50% probability,
uh, to a major systemic risk, uh,
incident if the damage at bear
Stearns had not been a contained.
But in any event,
while noting the necessity of all of that,
I want to emphasize it's insufficiency,
that it does nothing about either the
reduction in capital and it does very
little about the reduction in desire.
Degrees of leverage that I would
suggest are at the root of the problem.
That brings me to what is I think
the second crucial tool of uh,
financial stability,
which is the most important financial
policy issue in the current environment.
And unfortunately by its nature,
it is difficult to tell the vigor
with which it is being pursued.
And that is the infusion of new
capital into financial institutions.
Notice that if financial institutions
raise their level of capital,
then at any given level of leverage,
they are able to raise
their degree of lending.
And you were able to re-institute
the intermediation capacity,
uh, that has, uh, been, uh,
that has been lost.
There is a crucial,
an internalized externality in our
current system of financial regulation.
Institutions are regulated and their
soundness is judged on the basis of a
capital ratio,
on the basis of their degree of leverage.
They are pressured rationally enough
not to have deposits that are or live,
but short term liabilities that are too
large relative to their degree of kappa.
Notice that an institution can acquire,
can reduce,
it's can improve its capital
ratio or reduce its leverage.
In one of two ways.
It can reduce its leverage by shrinking
its balance sheet or it can reduce,
it's a leverage by expanding
its level of capital.
If the institution is indifferent
between those two choices,
society is clearly not indifferent.
Uh,
between those two choices,
it has a strong preference
for the issuance of capital
or to put essentially the
same point in a different way.
If an institution raises capital,
it dilutes its shareholders
and a substantial part of
the benefit of that extra
capital goes to the holders of it's risky
debt whose claims have now become more
secure.
As a consequence,
the private incentive for capital raising,
even with a capitol rule operating as
regulation is substantially less than the
social incentive.
One hopes that the regulatory system
is internalizing this externality is
placing substantial pressure
on institutions who after all,
are enormously dependent on
their relationship with the
financial authorities to
raise more capital than
they otherwise would.
It is very difficult to know
from the outside to what extent,
uh, that is, uh, taking, uh,
that is uh, taking place, uh,
eight prudent regulator who was forcing
an institution to raise more capital,
would conspire with that institution to
not have it be known that the regulator
was forcing the institution to raise
more capital last the health of the
institution. Uh, come into a question.
Certainly there have been a number of
favorable developments involving the
raising of capital in a recent months,
but uh,
in my judgment and uh,
the kind of numbers I presented
suggest that we have a long way,
a long way to go,
I would suggest a particular
importance in uh, this,
uh,
re in this regard is the capital
situation of the government sponsored,
which are levered 30 to one and which
have a crucial role in this environment in
supporting the mortgage market.
To date,
they have been encouraged to buy more
mortgages through a reduction in their
capital requirement and there have been
rather diffuse statements about it.
Is there hope and intention to
raise more capital in the future?
We've been moving towards the
future. They have not yet raised, uh,
the capital.
Some rather skeptical statements about
the need to raise capital have come from
their management with as yet
relatively little criticism,
uh, from, uh, the public authorities
liquidity, raising, uh, capital.
The third broad policy question involves
direct more direct intervention,
uh, in, uh, markets in my judgment,
any attempt to support the housing market
in general at current levels would be
misguided.
There's little reason to believe
that house prices have yet fallen to
fundamental levels, let alone
fallen through fundamental levels.
The lesson of the Japanese experience
is that price keeping operations by
governments delay processes of adjustment.
Why would anyone want to buy something
whose prices being supported by the
government? Since it's likely that
there will be further downwards,
a adjustment rather than upwards,
uh,
adjustment where there is a much stronger
case is for policy to support the
mortgage backed security market where
prices reflect expectations of terrible
perform terribly high
default performances.
Some mortgage backed securities
on some classes of subprime debt.
Our building in the expectation
that more than half the houses, um,
will be foreclosed.
Estimates that go way beyond what even
fairly pessimistic forecasts suggest by
stealth.
A rather substantial program of support
for the mortgage back securities market
is um, uh, is underway.
Key elements include the actions of the
government sponsored enterprises that I
referred to that will enable $180 billion
of increased purchasing of mortgage
back securities,
a similar change on the part
of the federal home loan,
a home loan, uh, banks.
And if with that 31 leverage ratio,
the GSES are caused to raise
a significantly more capital.
There is the prospect of
significantly further support for,
uh,
the mortgage back securities market
who's greater health would impact both on
the availability of credit to potential
new homeowners and the availability,
uh,
and the health of the financial
institutions that are holding,
uh, their securities. I think,
and I will not dwell on the point for
reasons of a time that there is also a
strong a case for policy measures
directed at strategic intervention in near
foreclosure situations to promote,
uh,
the writing down of
mortgages as an alternative,
uh,
to foreclosure.
Given that available
estimates suggest that, uh,
the losses associated with the foreclosure
process itself can easily add up to
more than half the value, uh, the
residual value of the home. Finally,
I would highlight the international
dimension of policy and with stress to,
uh, aspects. The, uh,
global dynamic here is that
two things are happening.
First,
uh,
US aggregate demand is falling second
the fall and the dollar ssociate it with,
uh, all the various ramifications of
these financial events are switching
expenditure from the rest
of the world towards, uh,
the United States.
Third,
some of the forces operating in the
United States are also operating to reduce
aggregate demand in the rest of the world.
A crucial priority for policy
coordination in that context has to be the
stimulation of aggregate demand,
uh,
in the rest of the world and probably the
achievement of a more balanced pattern
of dollar depreciation.
To date,
the dollar has depreciated
disproportionately against
a very small number of
currencies, principally the euro, uh,
that stand for countries that do not
have problems like those of the United
States and that allow their exchange
rate to fluctuate a more balanced path
would be desirable.
Second priority for policy coordination
is with respect to the very large
quantities of liquidity that
are now managed by governments.
They represent potentially and enormously
important resource in the current
context pools of patient capital that
can be managed for the long term and that
can provide,
that could provide liquidity to badly
distorted fixed income markets but have
not yet done so on a substantial,
uh,
scale.
These sets of,
uh,
measures represent,
I believe a policy approach that offers
a very good though not certain chance of
containing the current situation.
The risks,
it seems to me are much more on the
side of it being pursued with two little
vigor than on the side of it
being pursued with too much.
And in particular,
the imperative of the
rapid recapitalization of
financial institutions stand
out.
I will for reasons of a time leave
a discussion that I had intended,
uh, raising questions about, uh,
the regulatory structure and changes
that might make crises of this kind less
likely, uh, in the future, uh, to,
uh, the question, uh, period.
But I will just make a five
telegraphic observations.
First,
it is the irony of financial crisis that
the very forces that caused it are the
opposite. Uh, are the,
are also the very forces that
are necessary to get out of it.
If the world's problem 18 months ago was
that there was too much greed and too
little fear.
The world's problem today is that there
is too much fear and too little greed.
The policies that would have been
highly constructive 18 months ago in
inhibiting undesirable,
uh,
lending are potentially counterproductive
today in inhibiting constructive
lending.
Second,
there's an overwhelming case for
stronger consumer regulation in all,
uh, financial areas. Uh,
if one studies carefully the extent to
its subprime mortgages at agregious,
interest rates were taken
on to help people get out
of credit card debt at super
egregious rates.
One has a sense of the greater complexity
of the problem and the need to view it
from an integrated
consumer. Uh, perspective.
Third, the government should
be paid for providing,
uh,
the safe should be paid for providing the
safety net and the modalities that are
necessary to do that, uh, need to be, uh,
carefully,
uh,
need to be much more
carefully designed so that a,
if everything works out splendidly in,
for example, the bear Stearns transaction,
the government will be a beneficiary of
the success since it's surely will be a
beneficiary, surely will bear
the burden if everything else,
um, is, uh, is lost.
Fourth, uh, the dominant pro,
the single most important area for
thought in thinking about the future of
financial regulation is the
problem of pro cyclicality.
Prudent behavior by individual
institutions involves
shrinkage of balance sheets
in bad times.
Everyone's effort to shrink bound
seats in a bad times has catastrophic,
has potentially catastrophic
consequences for the system.
How to regulate to avoid pro
cyclicality is a fourth, uh,
crucial,
imperative and fifth,
these issues should be addressed slowly,
carefully,
and uh,
deliberatively as I suggested,
the problems of getting us
out of a situation of this
kind are in many ways the
opposite of the problems of
preventing future financial crises.
It will be tempting,
but would be unfortunate to address the
concerns through a what ever officials
do when they're not sure what to do,
which is reorganize our central
is our central challenges involve,
uh,
the questions of how we define capital,
how we regulate capitol for
whom we regulate capital,
how we avoid pro cyclicality.
Until we know the answers
to those questions,
it will be difficult to
think intelligently about
what the right bureaucratic
structure of regulation, uh, is.
All of this is to suggest to the students,
uh,
here that the macro economics of the 21st,
early 21st century will be no less
important than the macro economics of the
latter part of the 20th century.
That that macro economics has a good
chance of being much more centrally
involved with financial issues than
the macro economics of the late 20th
century.
Or perhaps fairness requires me to say
the macroeconomics practiced outside of
new haven in, uh, the, uh,
late 20th century and the many,
many in precisions,
uh,
and speculations in, uh, these, uh,
remarks,
I apologize for,
but offer as a modest and inadequate
defense that they point up that there's a
great deal of very valuable research
to be done that will contribute to our
understanding of economies.
And also I believe to art Ocwens vision
of harnessing that understanding to help
make better and more secure lives for
our fellow citizens. Thank you very much.
[inaudible]
I went over my time,
but I've got some time for questions.
Jeff.
Recommendations
answer to a
problem this year will die on the vine.
Die. Get traction on the
vine. I guess. Um, the,
you know, there's certain, I'm going
to not associate myself with, uh,
all the words you used in
describing the secretaries, um,
secretary his proposals
so I can understand why I
can't understand why you use
them. Oh, I think that, um,
it is almost always a good
idea to bet on inertia,
um,
in anything political.
I suspect that,
uh,
in the remainder of this election year,
it is very unlikely that anything will
get done that doesn't appear necessary to
respond to current difficulty. And, uh,
usually when there's a new
administration or a new secretary,
um,
the problem is,
is not excessive fealty to the
visions of the previous secretary.
The problem is a desperate effort at
artificial product differentiation. Uh,
there were a number of issues I found
when I was at the treasury where there was
a certain way to do it.
That was kind of a good idea.
And actually our predecessors
had more or less figured it out.
And it was my experience
that we never decided to say,
let's really work to get secretary
Brady's good idea in place.
We always found a few points of minor
difference and found a variety of ways of
relabeling it.
And that was when we thought the ideas
were good and he had it right. Um,
in the cases where we didn't,
it was much more dramatic.
So I would be surprised if,
um,
the ideas contained in that report
proved to be a dominant starting point,
uh,
for a discussion to be,
to be sure to be sure to be sure.
I didn't want to say one thing.
There is one thing that that report was
getting at and there is one aspect of
our system that I think we need to think
very carefully about and it goes deep
and that is do we believe in competitive
regulation of financial institutions?
We have a banking system and it has
for a long time been a fairly sacred
principle that we have a so
called dual banking system.
And the idea is, well, you know,
you get to choose your regulator and
therefore no regulator can be too stupid
because if they're unreasonable or stupid,
then people will choose a
different regulator. Well,
that's one way of thinking about it.
Another is that if regulators like to
have more jurisdiction and they like to do
more stuff, uh, competitive regulation
is the prescription for limited,
uh, regulation and implicit in, uh,
Secretary Paulson's, uh, sort of, um,
in the language one might expect,
uh,
from a republican emphasis on efficiency
and the avoidance of duplication,
um, was, uh,
moving away from a competitive regulation.
And I suspect that may be
quite an important idea.
you
repeat?
So it's a question, uh, said, uh,
oh, come on, don't Tuck the
question. I'm going to rephrase it.
I'm going to rephrase the question. The
question was okay. All right. That's good,
but don't duck all the
interesting questions. Uh,
there's a lot of experience in
a lot of places in particular,
England has a single financial regulator.
If you had to guess right now,
what's the best way to do it? Um,
it's not a fair rephrase this.
Is that a fair rephrasing the question?
Uh,
10 I think that,
uh,
the
three things I would emphasize
are competitive regulation
is probably a mistake.
If you believe in a regulation
that
the central bank does need to have a
role in financial regulation of major
institutions.
Because if it doesn't have a role in the
regulation of financial institutions,
it's not going to know things that it
does that it should know and it's going to
end up living with the consequences.
And so the central bank
should be crucially involved
in the regulation of major
financial institutions.
And that it's a,
if you believe in regulations that
are pursuing objectives that are not
immediately in the interest
of financial institutions,
if you believe in those regulations,
consumer regulations as a
community regulations and the like,
if you believe in those regulations and
you want them carried out with vigor,
you need to give them to their own
regulator who is not responsible for the
health of the institutions
in the way that, uh,
the Federal Reserve is.
So separation of consumer regulation,
elimination of competitive regulation
and regulation of major financial
institutions by an entity,
by a single entity in which,
uh,
the central bank has a role would
be the three principles, uh,
that I would suggest.
John,
you
all enjoyed your talk very much louder.
Calming. He enjoyed the talk that that
tends to that. That's the kind of thing,
that's the kind of thing you say before
the devastating question. And uh,
I knew John when we were in graduate
school together and nothing in my four
years of going to graduate school with
him makes it less likely that after he
said he really enjoyed the talk, that the
devastating question was going to come.
So I embraced,
well,
I thought at least I got the comment,
which was that he really liked the talk.
I would, that didn't even count at all.
Okay. Go right ahead. Don't
seem to have followed through
to the end of the story,
which is that you think that the marriage
is not being set by supply and demand
properly, too much in good
times and not another bad times.
When I thought he was
from the question periods,
I'm giving you a chance to say then you
would think that regulators to change
the leverage. So, for example,
in good times they could prevent people
from the leverage so much and in bad
times it's a little more difficult
to see what you could do.
Particularly what I
want you to talk about,
how can a fad intervene in a
way to increase the leverage?
For example,
should it directly against collateral,
but the lend more money
against collateral,
then the market is willing to do not lend.
The lower interest rates were just
saying on your mortgage derivative,
which the market lonely men,
$50 on the Fed will take
that as collateral and lend
at the same interest rate
the market will,
but mine is $60
the second,
the second question is
about the housing crisis.
In this 50% of houses,
you know,
people may be from subprime borrowers as
two and a half million of them might be
tossed out of their houses. And you
said at the same time that you know,
you think intervention sometimes
make it worse, but I mean, do you really,
this hundred 80 billion you spoke of is
not going to make much of a dent in two
and a half million families
being tossed out of their houses.
So do you think there should be some more,
a bigger intervention?
And one that I would suggest is the people
doing the editing or the ones who are
going to lose all the money when
these were thrown out of their houses.
They're the ones with the biggest
interest to see something done.
They're paralyzed because the bond holders
are split up so completely that they
can't coordinate there. Uh, you know,
modifying the terms of the loan.
No single banker,
you would let two and a half million
families be thrown out on the streets and
have their houses sold
for 50% of the loans.
So can you think of a way of
coordinating these people,
these lenders who aren't coordinated so
that they themselves without the mark
look, government having to put up
any money can help solve the problem
characteristically characteristically?
Good,
good questions on the first,
on the first question,
which was about procyclical uh,
leverage.
I'm not,
as I tried to explain,
I'm not sure the focus on leverage is
right rather than the focus being on
lending and those are very,
those are quite different things.
I actually think that
the world is more risky.
The uncertainty surrounding what's going
to happen to loans is greater than it
was a year and a half a year then
certainly then people perceived it to be a
year and a half ago.
So I'm not sure institutions should have
much higher leverage today than they
did a year and a half ago.
That's why I put emphasis on
what I think is the right thing.
I'm not sure they should
have more leverage,
they should have more lending and there's
a way of getting them more lending
without having more leverage,
which is raising more capital.
And that's why I emphasize the,
uh,
that's why I emphasize the importance of,
pressuring institutions
to raise more capital.
And that's why without having any
terribly compelling way to con,
to concretize it,
I think in our thinking about regulation,
we need to get away and get a bit away
from the capital ratio as the central
variable. Since we, what
we want is capital raising,
uh,
now not balance sheet,
not balanced sheet shrinking.
And an emphasis on the capital
ratio treats those two as
equivalent when they're
not, uh, when they're not.
In fact, uh, equivalent.
You know,
the one suggestion that has been made,
and I have no idea whether it
actually works out in a viable way,
is to force institutions to issue a,
some kind of security that is a reverse
convertible that that becomes the
converts from debt to equity, uh, in,
uh,
difficult times.
It's hard to see why that security
is going to feel a lot like debt, um,
when you buy it, uh, in, uh, the, uh,
in the good time. So, I'm not
sure whether that works out,
but that's the type of thing that one has
to think about. But I would resist, uh,
the,
I would,
I would resist the idea
of framing the question,
uh, through, uh, the
leverage ratio should,
uh, should the government, um,
try in good times to require,
uh,
levels of capital or limits on leverage
that go beyond what appears to be
potential for individual institutions
in the name of protection of the system.
Uh,
I'm probably one big financial mass
away from being in favor of that,
uh, and not quite, uh, and not quite,
not quite there because I think you
gotta be very careful about the adverse
effects if you don't do it very carefully.
Once you're talking about a punitive
capital requirement that's not related to
your institution's prudential needs,
the incentive to avoid it is very strong.
And so if you don't do
it for every institution,
the action's gonna Migrate Away.
And if you do do it for every institution,
you're getting to a pretty
dear [inaudible], um,
place in which the government is
regulating in a lot of places where it's
probably not going to
be so good. Um, at, uh,
at regulating. Your other question
was about the foreclosure and, uh,
the mortgage a problem.
I think one of the easiest
judgments to make in the sense that,
uh,
there's a measure available that has a
reasonable chance of doing good and has,
I think roughly no chance
of doing bad is uh,
the legislation that's been introduced
by Senator Castle and others,
uh,
to remove legal liability
from servicers for,
uh, any decisions they make to
renegotiate the total value,
uh,
of these mortgages.
I think there's considerable doubt
as to how much activity that,
how much positive activity
that would generate,
but there's no downside and
potentially some upside.
There's also another interesting
problem in this area,
which is many subprime mortgages,
probably more than a third,
have second liens,
um,
against them that are serviced by somebody
other than the original originator.
Anybody's good plan for working these
things through where you reduced the value
of the house, um, is in effect
in wipe out that second mortgage,
but it is going to require the
consent of that second mortgage.
And that second mortgage doesn't have any
very strong incentive to give consent.
And there's a long and dubiously honorable
financial tradition of being paid to
be a holdout.
And how one handles that is a
potentially serious problem,
not least because if it's financially
and economically advantageous to do so,
people who are good at being holdouts are
likely to acquire a substantial number
of these second mortgages.
And so the holdout rights will
be exercised more skillfully, uh,
then the than they would be
by their current holders.
I guess my reaction is to request is
can the capital markets handle it?
Yes.
At a price.
And the price will be that
they facto in this environment,
the demand curve for
equity slopes downwards.
And so if a lot of equity needs to be
raised to the price will be lower than if
a small amount of equity, uh, needs,
uh, needs to be, needs to be raised.
And so share owners of these institutions
are not wrong to be hoping to reduce
the amount of capital they have to,
uh,
raise that is rational behavior on,
that is rational behavior on their part.
Um,
but it may not be desirable from
the point of view of the system.
Oh,
I don't think we have a,
I think with the trillions of dollars
sitting in sovereign wealth funds with the
very large volume of assets that are
held by pension funds and endowments and
Life Insurance Companies,
I don't,
I don't think one needs to fear that
if a $200 billion more in capital was
infused into us financial institutions,
that somehow there'd be a generalized,
you know,
relative prices would
adjust in various ways.
But I think the least of
the concerns is that, uh,
somehow we'd have a general
general shortage of capital of,
for, for other purposes. I
think there is a, you know,
there, there is a, uh,
this is a tricky subject in the sense
that everybody's got the same idea,
which is that they want to be
the last dollar of equity in and,
uh, because you don't want, you want to
be in after the dilutions rather than in,
uh, before, uh, the dilutions.
And so there's the concern that when you
speak of large needs for capital that,
uh, they're, the incentive
to be a partial solution, um,
may not be that great.
On the other hand,
the strategy of sort of deception, we
only need a little and then we'll be done.
We only need a little,
and then we'll be done also is probably
not a strategy that can be carried on
very successfully for
a long period of time.
And that's why somewhat more
comprehensive, somewhat larger approaches,
uh, to capital raising, uh, would,
it seems to me be desirable,
Gus.
Oh, uh, I suspect, uh,
there should be a contingency plan
that is in place to give more rebates,
um, during the tax filing
season, uh, next, uh,
next spring that, uh, somebody
can decide to pull the trigger on.
We're not to pull the trigger on a late
next fall as we see where the economy is
and there should be some supplementation
of unemployment insurance and food
stamps and there should be,
uh,
they should almost
certainly be some effort to,
uh, reduce the pro cyclicality
of the state and local sector,
um,
which,
because of balanced budgets and less a
tax collections spending of all kinds as
being a cut back.
I say almost certainly because
there is a bit of a problem if the,
uh, history of fiscal federalism in the
United States is that whenever times are
good states,
governors cut taxes and
whenever times are bad,
the federal government provides support,
um,
to respond to the emergency.
That's not a terribly
healthy set of arrangements.
And there was a lot of tax cutting going
on in the good times. But on balance,
um, I think a, the right,
there are a variety of
mechanisms including medicaid
reimbursement for doing it,
but doing something for state and local
governments would be the other piece I
would emphasize.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Oh, I think, um, most of
most of the positive feedback mechanisms
that I talked about yesterday
were operative both going up and,
uh,
going down in the housing
and mortgage security, uh,
market. Uh, it's not that you can't
understand why people made these loans.
The truth is that in the period
from the late 1990s through 2006,
no matter how crummy the person,
no matter how many coke crummy,
the credit of the person
you lent money to,
you did not get defaulted on.
And the reason was that
if he bought a house,
the house went up in value and he was
able to borrow more, uh, to pay you back.
And so the lesson that was learned
was that lending money to people,
even people who didn't look like they'd
be very credits, very good credits,
was a safe thing to do.
Now it's post,
we can see what the error
and the inference was that
it presumed the continued
strong behavior of house prices,
but that wasn't completely obvious.
Um, uh, that was,
I was less completely obvious at the time.
And then you had various other things
people may be investments in day six.
You know, if you were in
the mortgage business, um,
you bought mortgages,
you succeeded,
your mortgages went up in value
as risk premiums went down,
then you had more capital,
you got paid on the basis of how
much you invested with more capital,
you decided to invest,
uh,
more so you'd all the kind of positive
feedback mechanisms I described on the
upside. And then you more or less
had all those mechanisms on, uh,
the downside.
No, those have an anti,
those have a very strong,
the um, if you like
Chicago school bent, uh,
make the, make the point. Uh,
so let's see who did well in
this situation. Let's see,
let's see who did badly.
Let's see. You did reasonably well
in this situation. Hedge funds,
nobody much regulates them.
They seem to have done, uh,
they seem to have done okay.
Um, individuals, you know,
some of them they got to know,
some of them got in trouble,
but some of them got loans on
terms that weren't very attractive,
that wasn't so bad, who
really made a huge mess. Well,
the big money center banks made a huge
mess who's most extensively while the big
money center banks or most
extensively regulated. So I get it.
We need more regulation is sort of the
Chicago is this sort of Chicago argument
and it's,
it should give one each.
I don't think it's the end of the subject.
I think it probably doesn't point in the
right direction at the end of the day,
but it's not a point a to be taken.
It's not a point to be, uh, taken lightly.
And, uh, since I liked the
spirit of your observation,
here's another observation
in the spirit of yours. Um,
so all these banks lost a lot of
money who made money or a ton of them.
A ton of the gain that is opposite the
bank's laws is a bunch of relatively poor
people who sold their houses
for substantially more
than they otherwise would
have. Uh, because of the bad credit, uh,
that the financial sector was prepared,
uh,
to was prepared to give. I think. Yeah.
I think the thing you have to say is,
uh,
that there are a fair number of
people who are having to explain to,
uh,
their children,
why a policeman is knocking at the door
and telling them they have to leave
within six hours because they signed
documents that they didn't understand and
that weren't explained to them,
that lock them into an arrangement
that was for them going to be highly
problematic.
And you can call it predatory borrowing
and you can explain how they lived in a
house in a sense, rent free for
a significant period of time.
But I think it would be
a mistake to a discount.
Uh, the trauma, uh, that, uh, has been,
that has been imposed,
but there is a sense in which a more
regulated entities have performed worse
than suffered more than less
regulated entities. Last question.
Let's
see.
Good day for
you now.
Seconds
also paid to know about that.
Are you driving through
you guys or private
look,
I think
there are structural similarities
between our problem and Japan's problem.
I think there are a variety of
reasons to think that the bubble was
substantially greater in Japan.
And I think if one compares US policy
in the last nine months with Japanese
policy between 1989 and 1992,
uh,
we are acting with substantial
more substantially more
aggressiveness to get in
front of, uh, the problem.
And you as regulators,
uh,
fortunately from my perspective have
been very resistant to what was a major
Japanese idea,
which was a mark assets in ways that will,
that, that it is thought will contribute
to confidence rather than in ways that
reflect market realities.
And I think that, uh,
the rather arbitrary accounting that
was pursued as a major tool of policy in
Japan,
uh,
inhibited a great deal
of necessary adjustment.
That said a while,
I think the probability is low.
One can't rule out,
uh,
the kind of situation that
developed, uh, in, uh,
Japan.
I think we do.
I think there's these issues of levels
of capital in troubled financial
institutions are,
um,
is a very important, uh, issue. You know,
one way of responding to an
externality is with a subsidy.
The idea of subsidizing institutions to
raise capitol seems quite untenable in
the context of the institution.
Shareholders holding onto their,
holding on onto their shares.
And so in a way,
we operate a system where the
government can't infuse capital into an
institution until the
situation is very far gone.
But once the situation is very far gone,
it is very far gone.
Uh,
I don't think it's inconceivable that the
government will have to infuse capital
into institutions on a significant
scale in the course of this crisis.
But I don't think we're ready yet to
start planning for a Nordic style or
Mexican style or Japanese
style socialization of,
uh, the finance of, uh,
the financial system.
Though I wouldn't,
I think the probability is very low.
I wouldn't preclude that,
uh, as a possibility.
And I think in retrospect, uh, it, uh,
came significantly later in Japan and
would in retrospective in have been ideal.
Thank you very much.